returning from near exhaustion but
thankful to be alive this is the moment
Timothy Shattuck set foot on dry land
after nearly three months adrift at sea
I'm feeling a lot better than I was I
can tell you
Shattuck arrived in the port of
manzanille on Mexico's Pacific Coast on
Tuesday aboard a tuna boat belonging to
the Grupo marfleet according to a
company's statement the 54 year old
Australian National was some 1900
kilometers from land when he was spotted
by the crew of a Grupo Mata helicopter
since arriving in the care of Mexican
Rescuers Shattuck has been sharing his
harrowing brush with death look I I feel
feel really good I
I thought you know the health was was
pretty bad for a while I was pretty
hungry and
um and I I didn't think I'd make it
through the the storm but now I'm really
doing good the crew of the tuna boat
turned rescue vessel say Shattuck was
found in precarious condition but was
swiftly given medical attention food and
water in photographs of the rescue a
bearded Shattuck can be seen smiling and
is now being compared to Hollywood actor
Tom Hanks in the survival drama Castaway
Shattuck told reporters he and Bella the
dog survived on raw fish and rainwater
and each other's company she's she's
amazing she's I mean that dog is is
something else you know a bit biased but
yeah
Timothy Shattuck was aboard his
catamaran Aloha TOA on a journey from La
Paz to French Polynesia when his
electronics were disabled by severe
weather
his tale of survival in the vast Pacific
Ocean now a testament to human
resilience Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera